this is no place to linger uranium is
refined and packed here for shipment as
fuel to 15 nuclear power plants in
Ukraine the facility is outmoded and
production and efficient the ore
deposits here contain only a fraction of
uranium the plant needs to be modernized
to approach the standards of competitors
so the director of Ukraine's state-owned
mining company is looking for investors
because time is running out so that's
the Buriti sue the state will no longer
be able to afford this there are
problems with the budget I think the
state should still retain ownership and
only enter cooperations with private
companies cockney Yom Kippur accusation
achieved not Golan offers have already
come from potential partners in Canada
and France but these companies also want
rights to mind their own uranium in
Ukraine as part of the deal and that is
taboo here
many observers in Kiev believe that's
because a network of influential
politicians and oligarchs control the
country's uranium industry and their
real roles would be exposed in a
privatisation threatening their profits
but Ukraine urgently needs more
transparency in its business dealings
this one of the biggest sources of
corruption in Ukraine would be closed
anvil point number three actually will
definitely world privatization would be
quite a good from my point of view
signal well to the inverse that Ukraine
is real actually determined will to
continue liberal type reforms but there
has been more progress in reforming the
nation's titanium mine production have
been controlled by the oligarch Dimitri
fear Tosh but his mind leases have been
cancelled
a trust agency has been set up to take
stock of titanium mining in Ukraine the
director's job is to figure out a way to
transform the ownership structure of the
two state-owned titanium mines in a fair
and open way no privity salsa that means
neither a privatisation through the sale
of shares or they remain property of the
state but at least two private
corporations but it won't be worked out
behind closed doors what should I look
at you the trust agency puts the value
of the country's annual titanium
production at about 2 billion euros
money that has so far mostly gone into
the hands of Dimitri fear Tosh with
little of it being passed on to the
state